I was doing doctor wallet thank you very
much doing fine how can we help you yes
I heard from you or not coast to coast
I am with all Joy's Norden mm-hmm okay
you want your 61 mm-hmm yes I had
diagnosis having a spinal stroke at the
Lambada quad that's really giving me
some serious back issues our down to my
caucus and I'm on it also our Jeremy
diminish our urination and our bowel
movements and I'm suffering with a
chronic constipation as well and um
variance learning from always on my
navel over down to my feet and I'm
losing weight due to losing appetite
because I am concentrating on okay when
you ate our way around 165 170 I'm six
foot four six four he's figure slim you
very slim you see dr. Baca
I was up to 200 pounds yeah okay couple
of questions we only have a couple of
moments here um did you ever have any
asthma as a kid or skin Tom's and eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis no okay
did you ever have any bowel problems as
a kid or young adult constipation
diarrhea diverticulitis or bowel
syndrome
I think about that all right others
bowel movements was not too sacred to
like three or four days before I have a
bowel movement okay mm-hmm did you have
your appendix out no okay
you didn't have this chronic
constipation yes okay and you have low
pressure diabetes no okay
char what do you think's going on with
Dale here probably got a gluten
intolerance yep I'd vote for that mm-hmm
and so he's had his final stroke and
we're gonna blood clot and some of the
arteries flying was fine maybe could
have been a correct diagnosis maybe bad
diagnosis okay as certainly he's got
some things going on
says his final function is impaired
because he has constipation could be
your bowel syndrome could be you know
colitis it could be from the spinal
stroke which may or may not be a correct
diagnosis also the fact that he has
urinary problems could say to the roots
to the spinal nerves that control the
bladder being affected what would you do
for this guy well I get him on a
gluten-free diet right away and I've
missed how much did you say you weighed
165 okay so he I think I was just get
him I would get him on to healthy brain
and heart packs and get him some gluco
gel - okay what would you do in case
there's some residual blood clots in
there then he could take either the
nightly essence or he could take the the
niacin plus either one okay very good
yeah you can take your nightly essence
you could take through those castles
beds have a glass of water you could
take the ultimate niacin flush you could
take two of those twice a day be two
bottles a month I certainly throw in the
ultimate daily classic tablets I go
ahead and take six of those a days for
your breakfast for dinner times two
bottles a month and the two healthy
brain and heart packs Tushar said I'd
also throw in the two bottles of the
gluco gel large bottles of Luca gel 240
calcium takes 15 and 85 at breakfast
five at lunch five at dinner in case is
really a degenerative disease in a
lumbar area and the the disc in lumbar
area is thin for Reagan close together
and being smashed by the verb rate
causing all those problems were waist
down
everything from constipation what would
you do for the constipation for him I
start out well he could start taking
some herbal rain forest at night before
goes to bed
yep I'm going to go ahead and sing a
5-pound start out with a tablespoon of
bedtime with herbal rainforest it's a
blend of 14 classic cleansing herbs
including cascara sagrada anthrax come
and put it in a half glass of water with
some again the tablespoon so one quart
will last you a month is is coming to
court bowels
actually one corner last two months okay
and if you go a month you don't get
diarrhea if you might try going up to a
full ounce and I want you to take a full
ounce to begin with so I want you going
from one bowel movement every three days
to ten watery bowel movements in a day
so you do have to be careful how you
start